one of the best things my dad did is the
following i went to my dad when they
said dad i'm 49 thousand dollars in debt
i need you to bail me out okay
i said you're my father you love me
you're my hero i need you to bail me out
he sat me and he said you're gonna learn
the best lesson for me today buddy i
said what's that
i'm not going to bail you out
i said but i'm your son i'm not going to
bail you out
i know you can figure out a way to get
out of this i think you're going to pull
it off this is a man who's a 99-cent
store cashier
who dropped out of school in eighth
grade his son almost followed in his
footsteps but i took four more years
okay but he dropped out in eighth grade
just to start working regular guy okay
for one week i don't talk to my dad
i go around telling everybody [ __ ] you
know your dad this and your dad this and
your dad does it you know my dad bailed
me out i can't believe your dad didn't
and i'm just bitching about my dad you
know what i did i came back and i said
i'm gonna pay this freaking money off
and i did okay eventually paid it off my
credit went from 484 495 499 to nice
credit score right
but my dad was not afraid of his son
failing
now if i would have failed
if i would have failed could i have gone
and retaliated against him and started
doing drugs and doing stupid [ __ ] to
hurt him of course
that's the risk a parent has to take
and that's the risk a nation has to take
some of these companies may go out of
business and it may hurt for a year or
two but we got to go through it we got
to stick through it and go through it
and i don't think
politicians
are allowing that to happen
because the people that are
supporting their campaigns
protect them and own them
and that's what i don't like about
american politics
the lobbyist who paul manafort sat in
your chair just two and a half months
ago
there are so many of them out there that
have bought these politicians and it's
screwing up low and middle-income
families families unfortunately i have
to say it's so spiritual what you're
saying like our whole religion is based
on the same principle which is that like
you know if you don't if you can't if
you don't have the option of failure if
you don't have the option of sin then
you also don't have the option of
redemption and nothing means anything
and and i think that is actually a value
that the american working class is
deeply attached to which is the idea of
autonomy like i want the fruits of my
labor i don't want to hand out i don't i
want the right to fail because without
the right to fail you don't have the
right to succeed i mean that's that's
can i just read the quick definition of
quantitative easing just to kind of
build your case a little bit just so and
i'm gonna process how i see and you tell
me if i'm understanding this correctly
so qe quantitative easing is a monetary
policy strategy used by central banks
like the fed
with qe central bank purchases
securities this is this is half of it
purchases securities in an attempt to
reduce interest rates increase the
supply of money
and drive more and here's the keyword
and drive more lending
to consumers and businesses like pat
said oh your credit card's five uh your
credit card limit is five let's bump it
up to 15. so this is kind of the
inflation thing is they just increase
the credit limit increase
the lending what's lending
it's just taking on more debt yeah
you're boring hey take on more debt
right but you're not making any more
money yeah you'll figure it out just
take borrow more money but i'm not my
business actually isn't profitable
that will bail you out we'll keep you
afloat and that's essentially what
you're saying is they're just increasing
the credit limit spend spend spending
spend but it doesn't seem like there's
justification based on your income
that's how i'm processing what you're
saying with the increasing the credit
limit yeah yeah listen
failing sucks
it's emotional it's painful it's
embarrassing it's publicly humiliating
you know in hollywood you know how many
like i saw a movie the other day with
nicholas cage a new movie that came out
you know what the movie is about it's
about the character in the movie called
nick cage
was the greatest actor in the world oh
god who no longer is that
needed to be
i think it's worth watching
but the whole story is about him wow
like it's a movie he's acting himself
but it's like
when they no longer want you to be in a
movie yeah do you know how hard that is
as an actor where you go from being
nicholas freaking cage to nick cage yeah
hey what's up nick
he ain't no nickname this guy
he won oscar
but the point is like
how hard is it when you do one bad movie
it flops in them
water world remember waterworld with
kevin costner [ __ ] i mean they got a
nice parking universal studios but
that's pretty much it and
just to pick you back i mean like you're
amazement especially like with pat who
who's such a such an amazing guy not
kissing ask for about that's listen to
this so i was in hollywood i was in the
military i was in the air force thank
you so much
my sisters are retiring of 25 years on
friday my brother was in for six years
you know went to there i know that god
put me here to make people laugh that's
my number one i know that's what it says
so fail well hollywood i've been on deaf
comedy jam i had a special kevin hart
called the next level which i think i
have grounds to sue because it's called
the next level and nothing happened but
anyway
so i got me and pat connected to you
know instagram and now i'm here and then
just just off what you were saying last
week pat you had like a php thing at the
other
office so he had like what 30 40 people
i walk in because we want to show the
sketch that we did on the video and i'm
hanging out pat's up there he's sitting
on the table he's doing a speech where
you were comparing pat uh greed and fear
and he made a chart with so much [ __ ] on
it i almost had a heart attack
but i just sat there and listened to him
for 20 minutes i almost quit comedy and
sat down and started selling [ __ ] no
i can't do that i almost started selling
insurance because i mean it was it was
like and again reading and getting all
that knowledge you fed your brain so
much it's like you could talk to them
about anything and and it's like a
lesson learned can i just one metaphor
that i think everyone will understand
here because we all know who the person
will talk about is but it's the freedom
to fail we all know the story of michael
jordan in 10th grade he tried out for
the varsity basketball team and what
happened he got cut
yeah so do you use your what yeah you
don't know the story about mike
i don't know anything about sports jesus
christ
michael jordan the greatest basketball
player potentially the greatest athlete
of all time the story goes in uh
wilmington north carolina he tries out
for the basketball team 10th grade
gets cut okay
wow so again with the freedom to fail
and he's very good right yeah mike
turned out to be pretty okay i don't
know how to check his resume the
greatest hockey players of all time
more goals than anybody you miss a
hundred percent of the shots you don't
take exactly
um
but
to use the analogy or metaphor i mean
you're the journalist here i don't know
if it's an analogy a metaphor either way
he had to go and improve
so rather than make excuses oh the coach
didn't like me or the parent comes and
talks to the coach hey do my kid like
you know uh
everyone wants a medal these days when
it's a trophy culture whatever it is
that these kids have these days um he
had to go get better okay and it turned
out pretty well for the guy okay but the
freedom the freedom to fail
is what inspired him to actually make
the teams the following year yes however
is there not a deep tension between what
you guys are saying on the one hand
about freedom to fail
taking responsibility you have the power
you have the ability
and on the other hand
this
quantitative easing
where if you're really really rich
the government's gonna come in and
protect you
like on the one hand yeah i see how it's
consistent with what you're saying on
the other hand to a little guy who he
doesn't get bailed out when he defaults
on his credit card he doesn't get bailed
out when he can't pay his loans he gets
his house taken away and i think that
that is something that you know
elizabeth warren and donald trump
totally
were in agreement about and totally
correct which is that there is a level
at which it is rigged on behalf of the
people who have already made on behalf
of the rich you're not going to go to
jail for white-collar crime because it
costs too much to prosecute it you know
but if you jump the turnstile you know
you're going i mean obviously now
progressives don't think you should go
away exactly you know you can kill
people and get away with it now but you
know that there's a level at which this
idea of accountability um adheres like a
gazillion percent if you're in the
bottom and like zero percent if you're
out there i agree i actually agree with
you and i don't appreciate that
i don't appreciate that i don't
appreciate when politicians get in there
and the guys at the top can buy them and
you prevent them from going out of
business let them fail
let them fail a great philosopher once
said let the boy watch
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]